what's going on guys
2016 coming to a close and we all know
about the movies that everyone is
talking about your Star Wars is finding
Dorries your fantastic beasts and where
to find them Captain America Civil Wars
but we here at screen junkies wanted to
take just a moment to recognize the
films that no one is talking about from
2016 that's why we proudly present our
maybe annual segment that came out this
year let's start with a film that has
all the ingredients for a hit talking
animals Kevin Spacey and Christopher
Walken as a witchcraft practicing weirdo
the film nine lives and it features the
classic plot of CEO Kevin Spacey being
trapped in the body of a cat while rival
tycoons try to steal his company you
know that old chestnut the studio is
hoping this film would have nine lives
at the box office but it pretty much
coughed up a hairball you are going to
tell them every word I say oh good move
this movie had it all cat peeing in
purse check cat hates bath check cat
hates getting selfies check how it
failed will forever be one of
Hollywood's greatest mysteries no won't
it was a weird idea just drown me
there's one thing we can all agree on
everyone loves Tom Hanks he's America's
dad but did you know he released two
movies in 2016 that's right - yep
before sticking the landing in Clint
Eastwood's Sully he starred in a
hologram for the King never heard of it
join the club
yeah it's a movie that came out this
year and it is about a hologram salesman
in Saudi Arabia who's trying to sell a
3d hologram meeting system to the king
you can listen to Tom Hanks say that
very thing I'm in Saudi Arabia with
the three-dimensional holographic
meaning system to the king there may be
no more reliable actor for critical and
box-office claim then Tom Hanks so uh
how the hell did this happen you know a
movie inspired by a toy has got to be
great wait no what I meant to say is if
a movie is inspired by a toy it's
probably terrible that my friends is the
cautionary tale of 90s toy turned movie
max steel check out some of this flick
that scored a whopping zero percent on
Rotten Tomatoes I even think that was
possible I can't say no that's not right
hold on
skittles something going well you just
pick what oh I like this one where did
it go fun fact
Twilight's Taylor Lautner was once
attached to this movie but dropped out
to do a Stretch Armstrong movie that
never got off the ground a cameo in the
Adam Sandler movie grown ups - and a
parkour movie called tracers hold onto
those ABS Taylor Lautner your career
depends on it
our next forgotten film from this year
is called the disappointments room DJ
Caruso directed this horror thriller
starring Kate Beckinsale ready for your
new house this is a new beginning
Thank You kitty her family moves into a
house that has a creepy secret room but
what's inside judging from the fact that
it was only in theaters for about 15
seconds and got no good reviews it was
probably something super lame this movie
opened in 17th place twelve spots behind
the wildlife another movie I bet you
haven't heard of that came out this year
is it just me or are you really tempting
fate by calling your movie the
disappointments room that's like making
a movie called this movie sucks or waste
of time and money actually I wish they
call nine lives waste of time and money
coming up next an actual movie called
clown forever and that's clown with a K
it's a pretty deep cut about a
misunderstanding that occurs when a dog
licks a guy's butt
those have been something you might but
some some song communites or something I
don't know it happened in split second
it just decide where the phone was you I
fear for Humanity because of this movie
I fear for our future you guys what
year-end list would be complete without
the love which the answer almost all of
them love me love me this movie is
fascinating for how much it basically
looks like a porno the craziest thing
about this movie it's got a 95 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes and they're not
reviews from like a bunch of no names 21
top critics almost universally gave this
movie a fresh rating so maybe we could
look forward to a sequel called the love
warlock starring me it's kind of like a
porno Harry Potter Harry Potter
Harry's Peter up next one of the
weirdest films to come out all year the
fun and bizarre indie movie Swiss Army
man Daniel Radcliffe stars as a dead guy
who helps Paul Dano find his way home
after being stranded on a desert island
but Daniel Radcliffe isn't just a
regular dead guy he's a Magic Dead Guy
Radcliffe's character also farts the
whole movie because dead guys the full
gas
[Music]
and also paul dano uses his dead guy
boner as a compass just like the sailors
did back in the old days huh I'm not
gonna lie this was a really entertaining
film and Daniel Radcliffe is
legitimately great in it you want to go
home so you can have one but you ran
away cuz nobody loves you but it
probably would have been easier for
Daniel Radcliffe just to record a video
of him shouting see I'm not Harry Potter
anymore no I don't want to audition for
the love warlock hey you guys remember
Dominic Monaghan from Lord of the Rings
and lost well in pet you can watch him
hold
Ksenia solo prisoner in a creepy cage to
be his sex slave I knew this is hard
it's hard for me too
what's that you don't remember seeing
any evidence that this movie exists
that's because it's only been released
in 139 7 million not 700,000 not seven
thousand not seven hundred seventy
dollars that's the lowest grossing film
of the year so far
what happens when you're the production
company and you get that final statement
and it's like we made $70 we spent ten
million goodbye cruel world Dominic
Monaghan I always liked you fingers
crossed for your next movie Hey
$80 well that was fun were there any
movies that we left out anything that
you were like oh they forgot this tiny
little movie also was there ever a movie
that you never even heard of you weren't
even expecting go see and it kind of
snuck up on you and you were like wow I
discovered a gem let us know in the
comments below I want to hear your
thoughts so we just talked about movies
that came out this year but you know
what's coming out next year a sequel to
Vin Diesel's extreme sports spy
franchise xxx the screen junkies news
team traveled all the way to Brazil hey
I want to go to Brazil to interview Vin
Diesel who said that xxx is the new Fast
and Furious kind of cool Andy
a sequel that's already in the works
check it out on screen junkies news I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye bye hey guys did you know
that this end card works with your phone
now I know right click the boxes below
to watch more screen junkies videos and
click the screen junkies logo to
subscribe and get this show honest
trailers movie fights and more